what was once considered science fiction
has now become science fact
earlier this week NASA announced the
planned April 17th launch of an
experimental satellite its mission to
search over 500,000 stars outside our
solar system with a goal of finding new
earth-like planets it's called the
transiting exoplanet survey satellite or
tests for short here with more about the
mission is CBS News science contributor
and City University of New York physics
professor Michio Kaku professor good
morning morning so tell us about tests
what exactly is Tess hoping to find out
there well the holy grail of planetary
astronomy is to find a twin of the earth
in outer space a doppelganger right and
tests may actually hit the jackpot
this is a potential game-changer could
analyze half a million stars yeah
identify 3,000 planets and among them
among them we might find this hit the
jackpot and identify an earth-like twin
in space this is amazing this is
something for the history books so this
isn't the first time NASA also has kept
large right to search for these other
potential planets how do these two
compare these two satellites
well Kepler was the first and identified
four thousand potential planets out
there but it only analyzed a small
little dot in the Milky Way galaxy
right it had a stationary target always
analyzing planets within that little
disk
however Tess is going to analyze the
entire northern and southern hemisphere
85% of the entire sky well how does it
do that
that's the buzzer he's gonna rotates
gonna rotate very precisely so that the
cameras will be able to take pictures of
large areas of the sky to look for
nearby planets now in two years the Webb
Space Telescope goes up into orbit a
replacement for the Hubble Space
Telescope and we hope to have pictures
get this actual photographs of these
Earth's like planets in space this is
amazing what would you say the
percentage of these undiscovered planets
how many are really earth-like and
potentially inhabitable well we can now
take a census of the Milky Way galaxy it
turns out that on
every star has a planet going around it
on average one in 20 have perhaps an
earth-like planet which means that in
our own backyard there are billions
billions of earth-like planets right in
our own Milky Way galaxy what would have
thought so when you search for new
planets of course there's always the
chance you might discover alien life now
the late Stephen Hawking suggested maybe
we didn't want to find alien life
because we wouldn't like what we found
what do you what's your take on this I
happen to agree with Mike my former
colleague got Stephen Hawking about this
because we don't know what their
intentions are we think they're out
there we don't know what they can visit
us or not right but if they can there
are hundreds thousands of years more
advanced than us you're convinced are
you convinced to this I'm convinced that
they're out there the odds are way in
their favor now because of all these
discoveries from from the Kepler
satellite and I think for the most part
they're going to be peaceful however you
can't rule out the fact that something
like what happened when Cortez met
Montezuma
yeah and the Aztec empire collapsed
within a matter of months two years that
cannot be ruled out so I think it's not
good for us to advertise our existence
to alien life-forms in space I want to
ask you about UFOs or on this topic here
so there was an American airline pilot
who said that he spotted some sort of
what appeared to be a UFO and then there
was another Learjet pilot who also saw
the same thing what do you make of this
well 90% of the emails I get you can
explain very easily as the planet Venus
comets meteors weather anomalies but the
last 10% sends shivers up your spine
because they could be a new form of
hypersonic aircraft experimented by the
Air Force there could be maybe
unauthorized weather balloons that are
not in anyone's chart or you can't rule
out they could be visitors from another
world there are actually radio
recordings from the pilots that were
published by a website if we can't let's
take a listen to those
[Applause]
there were seven one Papa golf good
[Applause]
seven one Papa golf negative again those
were that's I think we heard an American
Airlines pilot they're talking about
something that passed overhead this was
published on our website a little eerie
when when it can't be explained that's
right and these are seasoned pilots with
thousands of hours of experience this is
not a lark this is not just some kind of
thing that someone saw one day no two
people saw it in two different jets yeah
and it means that we have to take these
things more seriously so I think the
government as we now know has been
leaking false information about UFOs in
order to divert attention away from the
stealth bomber and different kinds of
experimental aircraft that are be
experimented with in area 51 so I think
the government should be a little bit
more honest about some of these
sightings all right professor Michio
Kaku thanks so much for being with us
this morning we look forward to what
tests will bring back